[Music]
well kids are heading back to the
classroom across the country and that
has parents of course shopping but some
are finding empty shelves supply chain
shortages impacting hundreds of consumer
goods and also leading to sporadic
shortages of school related items there
are also higher prices because of
inflation anthony pereira reports
kids are heading to the classroom many
for the first time since the pandemic
started you excited to have your kids go
back to school
i know i am i don't think they are
you're excited to go back to school
but some parents shopping for supplies
are finding slim pickings we just
started and i see that everything is
empty pandemic related supply chain
issues impacting hundreds of consumer
goods are also leading to sporadic
shortages of school related items
they're missing pencils folders
everything is not here in places where
shelves are stocked shoppers are finding
slightly higher prices because of
inflation that doesn't seem like a big
deal when you look at it on an item by
item basis but when you get to checkout
and you're shopping for multiple kids
and paying for everything in your cart
parents are really going to feel that
kristin mcgrath with retailmenot says
the most money is being spent on clothes
and shoes followed by electronics
schools release specific school supplies
that every kid in the area is going to
be needing so if you haven't completed
your shopping or you haven't even
started now is the time the national
retail federation predicts back to
school shopping will hit a record 37
billion dollars this year with the
average family spending nearly 849
dollars
but it might not be so expensive for
carolyn mushmel tawil because her kids
only did remote learning last year we
have so many supplies from last year
that we barely got to use
so we're probably going to be able to
use most of those parents are split on
where to shop retailmenot says 52
percent are buying in store the other 48
percent are making purchases online
anthony perez cbs news los angeles
according to the national retail
federation college students and their
families plan to spend about twelve
hundred dollars on average